i'm exactly in the middle of the
tournament
so 27 out of 54.
do i play a stafford let's play stafford
i insist
hey for gamba time h3 i play g5 new move
hey i haven't had too much experience in
this so
all i know is rook g8 and g4
um
yeah this is already a new position i
think i'll start with queen here
idea of queen f3 then g4 also
threatening this
there's queen f4
yeah maybe it's not too special
but it's interesting the new stafford
prep
we'll see how good this actually is i
have this move now i do knight g3
there's also just bishop e6 which kind
of looks nice
complete development
now i can take with rook
so i'm still down the pawn but
got my half open g file
this should be two i'll play rook g5
reasonable move
i might have to lose another pawn
i might have to play this actually an e5
actually knight g4 is kind of
interesting the idea is i put the
rook back on g4 and i play rook g8
and queen g5 so i'm down two pawns but i
want to win this
guy and also target this
wow white's just defending so i can
maybe grab a pawn
oh there's a funny line
what involves
i should start with this
i'll start with this hitting the rook
and then idea to take if b3 i play queen
a1
so i want to pawn back still down the
pawn
can i take this oh no that doesn't work
um have this move
having the battery maintaining the idea
of queen a1
interesting
put the bishop back i don't mind the
trade because then g2 will be more
vulnerable if this i have to defend
the a5 here
a5 why not
and there's bishop see four
possibilities as well
maintain the rook
oh i got forked kind of but
actually i take
wait this move
it's still interesting the knight takes
i take the rook
the threat needs to take him in the pawn
and a four i still take
okay
i can take and allow the fork
okay that was equal material
this down a little bit of time
[Music]
so
rook wants to be on eight
if rook f8 i mates
wow look at this game wow that's a nice
game
oh and this g5 stafford
let's uh i mean probably led to like
slightly worse position but it's still
interesting
um and got some
yeah still got some play in the end game
it was a nice finish too
because even though like i'm down upon
white has a connect four
the king the king was being cornered
um as nice idea too given
when the rook is in the corner it has
access to
the two other corners to attack the king
in the fourth corner so it's one big
square
so if rook here i made and otherwise i
made this way
so i think it's just force made in this
position yeah
okay made in four otherwise i'm not
winning
only move oh i'm playing a game okay
i have to put that on youtube more
stafford worthy content